ERIC KOLEDA: I'm going to
be talking now about the
TrafficEstimatorService,
specifically the new
TrafficEstimatorService that was
launched in v201008, and a
little bit about how it's the
same and different from the
v13 version that you
may be using.
It was originally released in
v12, so it's been out there
for a little while.
And it basically takes the
same functionality as the
TrafficEstimator UI, figuring
out for a given keyword, and a
given bid, and a given set of
targeting, essentially, how
many clicks can I
expect to get?
So it differs it a little
slightly from the
TargetingIdeaService with a
keyword pool, which is more
about how much traffic is there
on this keyword, how
many searches take place?
This one's taking it a little
further with, given a bid,
given how competitive that
keyword is, how many clicks
could I expect?
And the nice thing about it,
too, is it can use contextual
information.
You can kind of pass it in with
these proposed keywords.
So if I were to add this keyword
in some hypothetical
ad group, in some hypothetical
campaign, how would it do?
But what's great about this
service is it can also take,
if you pass in the IDs of your
existing ad campaigns and ad
groups, it can use the
historical information about
how well your particular
campaigns and ad groups
perform to kind of shape
the results.
So a v13 request had a format
kind of like this.
There's different ways
you could do it.
And I'll talk about it later.
But, essentially, you start
with a campaign request.
This is kind of emulating
the campaign-level
details of your request.
It's got things like
geo-targeting,
language-targeting.
So in the context of a campaign
that had this
targeting, how would
the rest do?
And then inside of that is a
series of ad group requests.
And each ad group request
has a max CPC.
If I had an ad group, and I set
the max CPC to this, how
will the keywords perform?
And then, finally, inside an ad
group request was a keyword
request, which was the actual
keyword that we're trying to
get traffic estimates on.
The key point about the
TrafficEstimator, in general,
is that it always does
keyword estimates.
It's not going to give you an
estimate on a whole campaign,
like this campaign will be this
successful, or this ad
group will be this successful.
It's always giving you per
keyword estimates.
But there's the ability to add
campaign and ad group-level
data to shape those estimates
to be more accurate.
And what you got back was a set
of information like this.
Look at the lower and upper.
You can see average position in
this case was between one
and three--
kind of a range of where your ad
might fall-- and then some
clicks and CPC data.
So how this has changed in
v201008 is not too radically.
You'll see it's got
essentially the same structure.
A series of campaign estimate
requests, ad group estimate
requests, keyword estimate
requests nested inside each
other providing contextual
information.
The same keyword
data is there.
You have the micro amount bid
for your ad group and then
targeting options like English,
the United States,
under your targets inside
your campaign request.
So the actual XML has
changed slightly.
But the idea is very,
very similar.
Now, what you get back is data
in a slightly different format
and, actually, some
new data, too.
So you get back, as you
had before, average
CPC, position, clicks.
You also get a total cost now,
which wasn't returned before.
And you can see there's also
a change in position.
So now average position is
kind of reported in a
fractional amount.
It's a little more detailed.
And the other thing you'll
notice too is it split up the
minimum and the maximum values
into two separate objects.
So before, your uppers and
lowers were together.
And now they're these two
separate objects that hold
your min and your max, but
they're actually the exact
same format.
So there are some other
important changes to talk
about I'll touch on quickly.
In v13 there were four different
methods to the
TrafficEstimatorService.
What I demonstrated before in
the v13 request that I showed
you was estimate
campaign list.
This is where you're passing
in a series of campaigns
wrapped in ad groups wrapped
in keywords.
You're getting the whole
contextual information.
v13 includes shortcuts, where
you can say, I don't want to
provide campaign targeting
information.
I don't want to provide ad
group bid information.
Just give me the most generic,
raw data about how this
keyword performed.
And so you could call estimate
keyword list without having to
pass in all those extra lapping
layers and just
passing in keywords directly.
So in v201008, those top three
had been combined to just one
get method.
What it means is that you're
always going to have to create
a campaign in an
ad group layer.
You can't skip right to
the keywords per se.
But we think that overall it's
a benefit, because thinking
about setting campaign
information, thinking about
setting ad group information
is going to give you better
traffic estimates.
And then the fourth method
there, check keyword traffic.
This was a very simple method of
the old service that, for a
given keyword, it just said true
or false, basically, does
it have traffic?
Does it get enough traffic
that it would
even serve at all?
It's been deprecating in the
TrafficEstimatorService,
because the same basic
information can be retrieved
from the targeting
idea service.
And so some other
changes here.
One is that in v13 you'd always
assumed you had a
budget of $50.
So if you are setting very high
max CPC on a very popular
keyword, it was just cutting
you off at a certain point,
saying, don't expect more clicks
than this, because I
assume you have a $50 budget.
In v201008, the budgets--
the sky is the limit.
It's going to tell you, if you
have infinite money, this is
how many clicks you
can expect to get.
And the other thing, which I
pointed out before, is that
the average ad position has
changed from being-- in v13 it
was a fixed range.
You either fell in one to
three or four to six.
Versus now, in v201008, the
ranges are more dynamic with
decimal values and more accurate
about where in the
range you're going to be.
And the last one there is that
average cost, which is
something that wasn't available
in v13, is now
available in v201008.
And then the last one here
is there is a slight
change in unit cost.
We've made it five units
cheaper, so if that's
important for you, then it's now
cheaper than ever to use.